lancé par dassault systèmes il y un peu
plus de trois ans le 3 d'expérience la
bête un laboratoire d'innovation ouvert
basé à vélizy villacoublay
objectif pour le leader mondial des
logiciels de création 3d mettre sa
technologie au service de scientifiques
on a un modèle de coeur parfaitement
exact qui permet à des médecins et et à
des biologistes d'appréhender le
fonctionnement d'un coeur à des fins
pédagogiques ou pour préparer une
intervention sur ce campus dassault
systèmes accompagne également des start
up qui développe des produits physiques
capable d'améliorer la vie quotidienne
environnement urbain on les modes de vie
avec trois des expériences labels
peuvent bénéficier de l'aide des experts
et spécialistes pour prototyper et
industrialiser leur innovation
l'objectif c'est de passer du niveau
local où on accompagne un réseau local
d'innovateur à un niveau global et faire
en sorte que ces écosystèmes puissent
collaborer les uns avec les autres ce
challenge et apprendre ensemble
entreprendre ensemble parce que vous
savez quand vous avez une bonne idée
quelque part ou pense être le seul à
avoir l'idée au même moment de la
planète vous avez une dizaine d'autres
personnes qui ont exactement la même
idée est donc de faire rassembler c'est
important rise robotics est une
entreprise américaine créée en 2011 à
boston
spécialisée dans la robotique elle a
développé une technologie qui remplace
les système de vérins hydrauliques avec
marc ona bord et avec dassault systèmes
à l'origine raïs d'utiliser solidworks
qui est un produit de dassault systèmes
pour design et nos prototypes et simuler
des tests avec le temps nous avons
trouvé des ressources nécessaires pour
des projets de management de fabrication
et plein plein de choses de dassault
systèmes pertinente pour rise robotics
aujourd'hui trois d'expérience lab
dispose également de bureaux physiques à
boston en inde et bientôt en chine